la série des chutes commence bartali
chute lourdement avec guide riches les
domestiques de la squadra se précipite
et leurs élèves partent ali souffre mais
si vraiment à ancelle et repartira
attention dont j'ai regardé à gauche
kessler sort de la route
gravement touché aussi sébastien hinault
son état a d'ailleurs nécessité une
évacuation
regardez bien l'homme de tête tout en
blanc ulrich il rate son virage c'est la
chute
cet après-midi les nz armstrong s'est
fait une grosse frayeur avec son maillot
jaune ici à gauche de l'écran
l'américain a frôlé la chute tout seul
un petit écart et se laisse regarder
bien laurent est coincé aux balustrades
c'est la chute
le drame abdoujaparov heurte la
balustrade
il entraîne deux autres coureurs dans sa
chute heureusement il porte un casque
l'image est terrible le choc
impressionnant mais le soviétique s'en
sort avec quelques plaies seulement au
cuir chevelu et à l'arcade
[Musique]